Hello, everyone,
and welcome to our third,
session in
the innovators track
for knowledge connections
twenty twenty.
It's been really
interesting so far,
and we're pretty
sure, you'll be,
satisfied with, this
talk, as well from,
Ines Sami,
who's a PhD researcher
in Stanford
University. Ines
will be sharing
with us today, Graph EDM,
which is a framework that,
they have developed
with her colleagues.
And it's about graph machine
learning and neural
networks and
different classifications.
Hello, everyone. My
name is Ines Chami.
I'm a PhD student
at Stanford,
and today I will
present a recent
framework for
buffer presentation
learning. This is a joint work
with my collaborators
from Google
and Stanford.
So this talk will
be split into
three sections.
I'll first start by reviewing
the problem setup for graph
representation learning and
discuss different variations.
I'll then introduce our graph
EDM framework and use it to
describe some
graph representation
learning methods,
both supervised
and unsupervised.
So let's first
start by reviewing
the graph
representation learning
problem setup.
As you probably know,
graphs are a universal data
structure used to store
relational data.
In this representation,
node represents objects and
edges represent relationships
between them. These graphs are
prevalent in many real world
applications. So
for instance,
knowledge bases
such as Wikidata,
which contains,
the Wikipedia,
data store knowledge
about the world
in the form of
the knowledge graph.
Form nodes are world entities
and edges represent
the relationships
between them.
Molecules can also
be represented
as graphs where
nodes represent
atoms and edges chemical
interactions between them.
And another
important application
is in the domain of biology
where the study
of evolutionary
relatedness between species is
done using
phylogenetic trees.
Note that there are many other
applications not
listed in this slide,
such as web and
Internet graphs,
recommendation systems,
economic and
transportation networks.
And so the summary
here is that
these graphs can be
used as a shared
vocabulary between fields.
And if we can develop methods
that operate on graph
structured data,
then we can have potentially
impact on many important
applications.
To apply machine
learning methods
and neural networks on graph
structured data,
we need representations
that a machine
learning model
can operate on,
and these are usually
feature vectors.
This is the goal of GRL,
which aims at
learning representations
for each vertex
in a graph while
preserving the graph
information.
So for instance,
if two users have many friends
in common in
a social network,
then good
representations should
preserve this information by
making
the known representations
similar in
the embedding space.
And these representations can
then be used as input features
in downstream machine learning
applications. However,
graphs are sparse, discrete,
and high dimensional objects,
and so it's not
clear how to get
a mapping from
a graph to a low
dimensional, dense,
and continuous
feature representation
while preserving
all the important
graph information.
And so we'll see next how to
design models that solve these
challenges. So there are two
main learning scenarios for
graph representation
learning,
supervised and unsupervised.
In the unsupervised case,
all we have is the input graph
structured data,
and we wanna
get representations
that preserve the graph
information.
Examples of unsupervised tasks
include link prediction,
where we wanna predict whether
two nodes are likely to become
connected in the future.
For instance, in
social network,
we may wanna predict future
friendship relations.
Other examples include graph
visualization and
graph clustering,
where we wanna put vertices in
a graph into
different clusters,
for instance, to
detect communities
in a graph.
In the supervised setting,
the goal is slightly
different.
And while we do wanna get some
vertex representations,
the goal here is to get
representations
that are predictive
of some graph properties.
So for instance,
in node classification task,
we wanna predict
the attributes
about nodes in the graph.
For instance, we could try to
predict fake
accounts in a social
network. And note
that in contrast
with the clustering task,
node classification
is supervised
in the sense that we do need
the label classes beforehand,
and we need some training data
to train the model.
Finally, another important
supervised task is graph class
classification where we may
wanna predict
an attribute about
the entire graph.
So for instance,
in chemistry,
we may want to predict whether
a molecule is toxic or not,
and this is
a graph classification
problem. So let's
now introduce
our GraphiDM
framework to describe
methods for unsupervised graph
representation learning.
The input in unsupervised URL
is a graph, which is
simply a collection
of nodes and edges,
and we store
the edge information
in the form of a sparse matrix
with zero and ones,
which is basically
the edges in
the matrix. We may also have
node features
representing the vertices
in our graph, and we'll talk
about these in more details in
the supervised learning step.
In unsupervised GRL,
we set mappings from vertices
in the graph to
vector representation
such that graph
similarities are
preserved in
the embedding space,
and we'll see next
how to define
these similarities.
So let's now describe
our GraphiDM
framework. As we've
mentioned before,
the input to GRL
models is a graph
that comes in the form
of an adjacency
matrix decoded to
construct an embedding
similarity matrix.
And these embeddings are then
decoded to construct
an embedding
similarity matrix.
Decoder network
can be as simple
as taking outer products of
the embeddings or be a more
complex neural network.
The parameters of the encoder
and decoder are
then learned via
gradient descent
using an unsupervised
objective function,
which essentially
tries to make
the embedding
similarity matrix
as close as possible
to the graph
similarity matrix.
The graph similarity
matrix can
be defined in many
different ways,
which gives rise to different
embedding methods.
So for instance,
some methods may
wanna preserve
the first order
graph proximity,
namely the AGSNC structure,
while other methods want to
preserve higher order graph
similarities. After
optimization,
we can extract
the word embeddings
and use them as features for
downstream machine
learning tasks.
Let's now go over
a simple example
of encoders, namely
the shallow encoder,
which is a simple
embedding lookup.
We can get the embedding
of a specific
node by doing
a matrix multiplication
of the embedding
matrix by the one
hot vector of
the corresponding node.
The parameters in
shallow encoders
are the embeddings
themselves,
and there are no functions
computed on top of
these embeddings.
In other words,
a shallow encoder is a simple
vocabulary lookup which stores
a single vector per
node in the graph.
Note that there are many other
possible encoders
such as graph
neural networks,
which we will
describe later in
this talk.
So let's now look
at an example.
We focus on
the graph factorization
model, which is
a popular graph
embedding method
that preserves
first order proximity
in the graph
by learning
essentially a lower
rank factorization
of the adjacency
matrix. In this model,
the encoder is
a simple embedding
lookup as we've seen
in the previous
slide, and the decoder takes
the outer product
of the embedding
matrix. That is,
the embedding
similarity between
two nodes is simply
their inner product.
The embeddings are
then optimized
by minimizing an unsupervised
loss function,
which encourages
adjacent nodes to have a high
embedding similarity and non
adjacent nodes to have a lower
similarity score.
Note that taking
the embedding's
outer product
defines a symmetric
similarity function,
which may have,
which may be
a limiting assumption
when working with
directed graphs
as some nodes can be strongly
connected in one direction and
disconnected in
the other direction.
There have been
follow-up works
for directed graphs which
basically define
two embeddings
per node, a source and
target embedding,
depending on the direction of
the relation it appears in.
Another line of work seeks to
preserve higher
order similarity
in the embedding space using
random walks.
In skip gram GRL,
the decoder function is also
an outer product but the graph
regularization
term is computed
over random walks
in the graph.
So for instance,
DeepWalk draws
analogies between
graphs and language
by generating
sequences of nodes
visited during
random walks and treating them
as words in
the sentence to get
representations. All these
extensions are described in
detail using GraphiDM
in our paper.
So let's now move
to supervised
URL methods.
In supervised URL,
the input data is the same as
in the previous case,
but the goal is now to learn
representations
that are predictive
of some vertex or
graph properties.
In this setting,
we have some
additional information
about the graph,
namely vertex or
graph labels,
and we want to learn mappings
from vertices in the graph to
some target label space.
One possibility is to apply
unsupervised URL
methods to get
representations and then use
them as input in
a simple neural
network. However,
an important
limitation of this
two step approach is that
unsupervised representations
might not preserve important
information about
the graph that
would have been useful
for the downstream
supervised task.
Supervised URL
methods overcome
this limitation by learning
representations and solving
the predicted
task end to end.
Finally, note that
node features
play play a critical role for
predictive tasks.
So for instance,
in citation networks
where nodes
represent papers and edges
represent the citations
between them,
we could have had
feature vectors
representing the paper such as
what you're making
for all the words
in a given paper.
And this information can be
critical in some
supervised settings.
So for instance,
if we wanted to predict
a paper topic,
then knowing that
some keywords
are mentioned in a paper can
significantly improve
the classification
accuracy. For
supervised methods,
we need to add an additional
branch in
the GraphoDEM framework
to account for
the label supervision.
Essentially, we add
another decoder,
which predicts labels
from embeddings,
and we still keep
the unsupervised
decoder, which can be used to
regularize the embedding and
account for
the graph structure
in the embedding space.
But note that some
methods discard
this unsupervised decoder,
and we'll see next
some examples.
So let's first talk
about the label
propagation model.
Given a graph that is
partially labeled,
we want to infer labels for
the other nodes in the graph
based on the connectivity
pattern.
And, essentially,
if two nodes are connected,
then they are likely to share
the same label.
The labeled
propagation algorithm
uses the graph Laplacian to
propagate labels
in the graph.
And to provide
more intuition,
the graph Laplacian
can be thought
of as a discrete
analog of the Laplace
operator, which
happens to model
the propagation of the heat
equation in
the Euclidean space.
In some sense, labels can be
thought of as heat
sources on the graph,
and applying
different iterations
of label propagation diffuses
the heat or labels
to unlabeled nodes.
While label prop
is an iterative
algorithm, it can also be
equivalently written
as a an optimization
based method, which allows us
to describe labelprop in graph
EDM terms.
Here the encoder
is shallow and
embeddings are
directly learned
in the label space,
so the label decoder is simply
the identity function.
The supervised loss term is
simply the l two distance to
the labels of labeled nodes,
and the unsupervised decoder
uses l two distances between
labeled vectors
to compare pairs
of nodes. And the unsupervised
regularization loss compares
these distances to the true
graph aj s and c matrix.
Minimizing this
graph organization
term essentially
will encourage
adjacent nodes to have their
labels closed in
the embedding space.
And we can show
that minimizing
the sum of the supervised and
unsupervised losses recovers
the iterative solution from
the previous slide.
Finally, let's
look at a recent
and very popular approach for
graph embedding.
All the methods we've covered
so far used shallow
encoders and
were therefore inherently
transductive,
in the sense that they could
only get representations for
nodes that were present at
training time.
The graph convolution model
generalizes convolutions to
graph by learning parametric
encoders using node features.
The total number of parameters
in this model is
independent of
the number of nodes
in the graph,
and the learned
encoder networks
can be used to
get representations
for many input
graphs that have
the same input
feature domain.
And this is basically
the inductive
setting where the models can
generalize across
different graphs.
One challenge in designing
convolutional neural networks
for graphs is that graphs have
arbitrary structures,
while usual neural network
architectures
operate on regular
data such as
sequences or images.
So for instance, in
computer vision,
CNNs are used for automatic
feature extraction by applying
small localized features which
activate in the presence of
relevant panels.
And due to
the regular structure
of images, these
filters can be
shared across many different
locations in the image,
making CNNs
computationally very
efficient. With graphs,
this is much more challenging
because graphs don't have this
regular grid structure.
So for instance,
the number of neighbors varies
from one vertex to another.
And so to solve
this challenge,
GCNs make many simplifying
assumptions by
adding some weight
sharing constraints
in the model
and also letting
nodes interact
with their direct neighbors in
these small filters.
So this is basically
the message
passing framework
where at each step,
nodes aggregate
information from
the neighbors. And as these
iterations progress,
each node embedding contains
more and more information from
further nodes in the graph.
This message passing allows to
preserve both
structural properties
of the graph, since nodes
communicate only with
their neighbors,
but also feature information
since these messages
are computed
from input features.
The GCN model can also be
described using GraphiDM.
In this scenario,
the encoder uses
both the adjacency
matrix and node features,
and no unsupervised
decoding is
needed since the structural
information is
already leveraged
in the encoding step.
The label decoder is simply
the identity
mapping as GCNs map
input features
directly to the label
space. And
the encoder functions
can be written in matrix form
using the adjacency matrix and
the degree matrix.
It first transforms
input features
to compute messages and then
aggregates messages via the
graph ID as in its structure.
Finally, GCN stack
many of these
layers using
nonlinearities and
the model parameters
are learned
by minimizing
the cross entropy
loss over the labeled data.
This is the end of this talk.
If you'd like to learn
more about GRL,
feel free to check out
our silver paper,
which has many more detailed
descriptions of
the different methods.
In particular,
I mostly focused
on methods that
learn presentations
in occlusion spaces,
but note that it
is also possible
to embed graphs
into non occlusion
spaces to better
match the graph
geometry. And so if you're
interested about this topic
topic is perfect to reach out
to me or check out our first.
Thank you for listening.
K. Great.
Thanks thanks for
the presentation,
Ines. And, good to have you,
here with us in
the flesh as it were,
even though, you know,
it's it's the closest,
it's the next
next best thing,
actually. So Thank
you. Our pleasure.
I see that people are just now
starting to to
type in some some
questions. So, I'll
give them some time.
And, I have actually written
down a few of my
own until we have,
some from the people.
So one question for me.
You mentioned at some point
towards the end of
the presentation
that one issue that,
you have when
using graph neural
networks as opposed to,
the the classic
ones that says,
precisely the lack
of structure,
and that forces you to you you
some some some
tricks, basically.
Could you expand a little bit
on on that?
What does the what
precisely is
the issue that the lack of
structure causes?
Because, you know,
this is not in any way my my
expert graph
machine learning,
but based on on the cube,
my the little knowledge I had
I had the impression one of
the benefits of using that is
precisely the ability,
to to add more
information and,
represents all kinds
of data structures,
basically. So can
you expand can
you explain a little bit what
we what that issue
causes, basically?
So just to make
sure I understand
correctly, because the network
is is breaking a little bit,
are you asking
about the lack of,
regular structure
in graphs and,
how it makes this issue?
So if you think
about an image,
it can be part
of it as a graph
in some sense, which
is a grid graph.
So just, two directions where
every node is connected to its
top left and bottom
right, neighbors.
So this structure is very
irregular in the sense that if
I move and I translate,
do some translation
along the image,
then
the neighborhood structure
is gonna be exactly the same
wherever I go. So each node is
gonna have, again,
a top left,
bottom right neighbor.
And so because of this regular
structure,
convolutional neural
networks on images,
can do many
simplifying assumptions
like, sharing filter weights
across different
locations in the image,
which makes them
very computationally
efficient, but
also allows them
to extract, local features at
different locations.
With graph, if we wanted to do
with a general graph,
not necessarily a grid,
if we wanted to do
a similar method,
we would have to design a way
to translate those
little features
across different
graph locations.
And because these graphs have
an arbitrary structure,
so one node may
be connected to
three other nodes and another
node may be connected to only
one other node,
it's unclear how to move those
filters across locations
in the graph.
So that's essentially
the challenge
in designing methods
that operate
on these graphs, for,
feature extraction and pattern
recognition. And
so, essentially,
the GCN makes,
some simplifying assumptions.
So for instance, the weights,
that are gonna
interact, from,
different neighboring
nodes are
all gonna be cool,
whereas in,
standard CNNs, we
have the flexibility
to have different weights for
different neighbor
interactions.
So we usually make
those simplifying
assumption to make these,
CNNs work on arbitrary
graph structures.
So I'm not sure if that under
that answers
the question. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. It does. It does.
It also brings up
a follow-up question,
actually. So these precise,
assumptions that
you mentioned,
how do you make them explicit
in some way, or
should you perhaps
make make them
explicit in some way,
like adding some
kind of metadata
basically to,
to to your network
so that you know,
like, okay. This
is my assumption
and this is the basis
I'm operating on.
The assumption about sharing
the weight constraints,
is that,
what you're asking
about? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah.
So when we design
the models, we,
explicitly have those
inductive biases.
And so we're gonna design,
convolutional
layers that account
for these assumptions.
So, yes, when we
design the models,
all these assumptions
are taken
into account, in
the implementation,
so that they can
work in practice
on on real graphs. Okay.
We have a question
from the audience
here from Roberta,
who's asking if you can please
contrast the impact between
shallow and deep
neural networks.
In other words,
what drives to increase
the complexity
and number of layers and
convolutions of the network?
The kinds of problems
or the accuracy?
So I think there
are two threat of,
like, research progress
in this field.
One is more driven about state
of the art. So we
have some datasets,
and we wanna improve the,
as as Roberto said,
the accuracy on
these datasets.
And so in this dataset,
it's really driven by,
architecture choices,
and we're gonna
make small tweaks
to see whether,
architectural change can make
improvement. And then I think
there's the practice where,
maybe those
architectural changes
are gonna give some
small improvements.
But then in complexity,
they're adding
a significant overhead.
And so we're gonna
go for simpler
methods that, can work
in practice and,
work efficiently.
So there are those
two threads.
And depending on whether we're
trying to get
a paper and, like,
make some research progress or
whether we're trying to use
these GCNs in applications,
to do some prediction
about real data,
then we're gonna be,
choosing one method
or the other.
Okay. Okay. That's
that's actually
something I also wanted
to to ask about.
If there are if you
you, specifically,
personally are working on
applications like,
industrial or real world
applications of,
of this framework.
So we've been working,
with knowledge graphs, a lot.
So knowledge graphs are,
specific type of graphs where
the relationships
have, edge types.
And so the application we're
considering is link prediction
in knowledge graphs.
So how can we use the,
how can we use the knowledge
graph structure to
predict missing
links, about, entities?
And so for instance,
in Wikipedia,
I guess people are familiar,
in the context of
this conference.
But so, like,
trying to predict
missing facts in,
in knowledge basis,
to complete, the the knowledge
graph structure,
and we're also using them for
natural language processing
applications. So because these
knowledge graphs have,
a lot of knowledge about real
world entities,
we can get
representations that
capture this knowledge,
and they can be
used, as input to,
neural networks that do any
language task like
question answering.
So we're working in this.
Like, for instance,
name entity disambiguation.
We have, we may have, like,
many entities in
the sentence that,
conflict with each other,
and we wanna know which entity
sentence is referring to.
So having these
knowledge graph,
embeddings that give us,
some more additional context
about entities can be,
useful in in those natural
language task. Okay.
That's that's interesting.
Actually, I just recently,
so discussion,
which seems very
relevant to to
what you're saying.
And it's been
actually an ongoing,
a long standing, let's say,
issue in the in the knowledge
graph board,
precisely what you
described. So being able to
infer additional,
additional links,
basically, between these these
different entities.
And so far,
the the general assumption has
been that doing that
is is a good thing.
But, recently, I
saw a discussion
with people some people,
including actually,
one of my mentors,
Frank van Harveen, like,
one of the leading scholars in
his domain, was was kind of
questioning this notion.
Like, the the idea
was and some
people were agreeing.
Actually, the idea
was that, well,
it it all depends
on on, you know,
how how accurate you
can be in this,
link, prediction.
If if it's not accurate enough
or even if it's not
very, very accurate,
you may be doing
more harm than
good with with this
section. Yeah.
Yeah. I guess this
is the precision
recall trade off.
So the model is gonna return
many answers, and we have to
choose a cutoff,
for when we consider
the answers are,
not confident enough.
So, yeah, this is
probably a challenge
with these link
prediction, models.
Like, we don't know when,
when to stop adding links in
the in the network.
Is there are you
aware of any,
any methods that
you can you can
set this this this boundary to
to be just about right?
I'm not sure because
in my work,
I haven't worked with, like,
explicitly the completion.
So we use completion to get
representations,
but then, like,
during test time,
we don't actually,
complete the knowledge graph,
but we just get the,
representations
that we've learned
for other machine
learning tasks
that require the knowledge.
So we don't have to make those
explicit choices for when,
to stop adding links
in the knowledge
graph. Okay. But
that's the interesting
point. Okay. Yeah.
Fair enough.
We have another question from
Matt who's asking how are
different meta
features on Edge
data managed in
the adjacency matrix?
For example, has a or belongs
to or is a in
a knowledge graph.
Quite relevant question.
In the talk that I
presented here,
I only considered graphs that
don't have edge types.
These were only whether two
nodes are connected or not.
In the general knowledge,
graph application
that I mentioned,
we've worked with graphs that
have edge types.
So, usually, the edge
types are just,
categories. So we know that,
has or belongs
to our different
categories. We haven't tried,
adding edge features
in the model,
but I know this is
something that,
people have worked on.
So, like,
maybe some relationships are
very similar to each other,
and so having
some representations
for the relations rather than
treating them as completely
different categories,
can improve
the model's quality.
But, I haven't
worked with edge
features, in in
my work. Okay.
Would that be perhaps
one, future,
future direction
for this research?
Yeah. Definitely.
And even in the just
in the graph,
neural network area,
I think there's been a lot of
work in trying to incorporate
those edge features.
So, essentially,
the GCN update,
aggregates messages
from the neighbors.
And, in the work in the talk I
presented, the aggregation is
just an average,
of messages from
the neighbors,
but we can also extend that to
incorporate edge features.
So when we aggregate
information,
we also have
some transformation
that accounts for the type of
relation that the message is
coming from. So these
are definitely,
ongoing research directions,
especially for,
knowledge graphs that
have, different,
edge relations. Okay.
Other future
directions for for
your work?
So my personal
research is mostly
focused on, nonaclegian
representation.
So I've, briefly
mentioned that
at the end of the,
the presentation.
Essentially, all
the all the methods
I've, talked about in the in
the talk were, occlusion in
the sense that
the representation
slide in occlusion
vector spaces
where we can take
inner product
l two distances.
And my research is focused on
nonacledian
representation learning.
So, essentially,
here the representations
lie in,
curved spaces. And so these
spaces don't have
a vector space
structure, so we
can't just take
two points and add them.
So for instance,
if you think about a sphere,
it's also it's
a space of positive
curvature. And if you have two
points on the sphere
and you do
the Euclidean addition,
then the points are gonna lie
within the sphere,
which is not valid,
does not respect the geometry
of the space, which is this
curved surface.
And so the challenge
is in, with this,
with this, spaces
is to design,
operations that can,
that are valid in these,
in these curved spaces to,
do machine learning
in, so for instance,
hyperbolic spherical spaces.
So this is the focus
on my research.
And the high level motivation
is because,
tree like data and hierarchies
in general can be represented
much better in
hyperbolic spaces
than in occlusion
spaces because
the hyperbolic space is like
some sort of
continuous version
of trees, and it
has a polynomial
volume growth. And so because
it has this growing
structure,
it's more suitable
to represent,
your archical data.
And so that's why,
we've been working
with those,
alternate geometries
to represent
your archival data. Okay.
Thank you very much.
It seems, we don't really have
many more questions.
Thank you so much
for having me.
Thank you very much.
Bye bye. Bye.